well the united states is watching
closely to criminal justice trials one
trial of course is the kyle rittenhouse
trial that is happening over in
wisconsin the other trial is happening
down in georgia over the killing of
ahmed arberi joining us on the line to
discuss both of these cases misty maris
she of course is a trial attorney based
in new york city specializing in the
defense of clients and entertainment
sports employment civil rights and
sexual assault abuse cases she's
covering both trials for hln she also
has a new podcast called the legal brief
on a new platform called colin misty
thanks so much for joining the show i
appreciate it thank you ben
so why don't we start with the written
house trial obviously that trial will be
coming to its conclusion very shortly uh
and it appears as though the prosecution
just humiliated itself i think everybody
who's watched this trial wonders why the
prosecution even brought the case in the
first place it does raise serious
questions it's a prosecutorial
discretion the prosecutor's own
witnesses seem to be defense witnesses
the defense witnesses made a mockery of
the prosecutor the judge obviously was
very upset with the prosecutor
throughout the trial because the
prosecutor kept trying to pull stunts
and also i think the judge was kind of
ticked that the case was brought in the
first place because again he evidenced
no actual evidence that rittenhouse was
guilty of murder rather than
self-defense
ben i actually went back and reviewed
the probable cause affidavit
which brought the charges against
written house and i was kind of
surprised i hadn't read it in a while
and i was shocked to find that most of
the information that we're seeing play
out in the trial that tend to support
a self-defense argument for kyle
rittenhouse was already in there it's
not like any of this was truly a
surprise i i always try and reserve a
little bit of judgment on these cases
until you really see the trial unfold
because we often times find new
information a new evidence that's
presented before the jury but that
doesn't really seem to be the case here
so there is a question mark about the
prosecution bringing this case and then
to your other point
i was really shocked at some of the
prosecutions uh let's just say
failure to know what their witnesses
were going to say on the stand rule
number one is that you know what your
witness that you put on that stand is
going to testify to and some of what
came out wasn't even surprising so i was
very shocked and then
just to just of my final point on the
prosecution
there were some stunts ben and quite
frankly it seemed like the prosecution
was actually trying to goad this to
become a mistrial because the case was
so
bad and unfolding so poorly for them
they violated a rule that you learn i
mean i think you learn it actually on
law and order quite frankly if you watch
that show growing up but you definitely
learn it your first day in any trial
advocacy criminal or constitutional law
class you cannot question the
defendant's right to remain silent or
question that he did remain silent or
bring that in before the jury
prosecution tried to do that second of
all they just violated a court order
where the court had precluded certain
evidence and they tried to bring it
before the court without asking for
permission first all big no-nos judge
scolded them and rightfully so and quite
frankly the prosecution's case was just
downhill the entire time defense
captured their witnesses and actually
made them into defense witnesses
so misty one of the things that i think
a lot of people were puzzled about and i
was puzzled about it too was the
decision by the defense to even put
written house on the stand the
prosecution had so thoroughly failed to
make its case that you always think as
an attorney that it's risky to put a
defendant on the stand you just never
know what the defendant is is going to
say and again if the prosecution fails
to prove its case the burden is on the
prosecution not on that offense were you
surprised that they decided to put
written house on the stand
you know i actually was ben and and it's
exactly what you said the prosecution's
case had already gone so far south as a
defense attorney it's one of the most
difficult decisions that you have to
make whether or not the defendant takes
the stand and it comes with significant
risk so if the prosecution
is not fulfilling their burden of
proving their case beyond a reasonable
doubt many defense attorneys will say
look it's not worth it because the
prosecution's case just is not strong we
don't need this you really only want to
put your client on the stand if it's
necessary however there is something
that all of the viewers should
understand the decision to go on the
stand and to testify lies with the
defendant himself so you can tell your
client
that they shouldn't do it you can
explain the risks versus the rewards if
they want to take the stand it's
ultimately their determination so i
think perhaps that was part of the
calculus that kyle rittenhouse has been
demonized uh for for this entire time
and perhaps he said to his lawyers i
want to do it and you know as much as it
did come with those risks i actually
think it was uh he did a great job and
in a self-defense case it is good for
the jury to hear what was actually going
on in the person's mind who is trying to
use that as a justification so i think
it ended up working out for them but it
is a risky decision we'll get to more
with misty maris in just one second
first this holiday season deck the halls
walls windows and doors with the best
deals of the year on the award-winning
ring alarm i'm sure we all know about
the ring video doorbell by now i mean
how could you not but did you know that
ring makes an award-winning alarm as
well ringalarm is a powerful affordable
home security system you can easily
install yourself so whether you're
running across town or across the
country this busy season you and your
loved ones can rest easy knowing your
home is protected and it's more than
just security ring alarm protects your
home from flood freeze and fire as well
plus it's so much cheaper than those
other companies for what they charge for
one month you get an entire year of ring
alarm with professional monitoring right
now for the best deals of the year on
ring alarm head on over to ring.com
forward slash ben every time i am out of
town i make sure that i check in on my
ring alarm so i can keep track of my
house keep track of the kids and
sometimes just sometimes my little kids
they're running around constantly i lose
track of one of them i need to use that
ring app to figure out where they are it
happens more than i would want to admit
actually so this holiday season protect
the halls walls doors and windows with
the best deals of the year on the
award-winning ring alarm head over to
ring.com forward slash ben get a great
deal on a ring alarm security kit today
that's ring.com forward slash gun
repeating misty mayor's trial attorney
based in new york city and she covers
all of these trials for hln so misty
let's turn to the other trial that
hasn't gained nearly as much national
attention as yet that's the ahmed arbury
trial i assume that if the defendants in
that trial are let off then presumably
there will be riots and and all sorts of
attention will be paid to the case but
this one is a more complicated case the
written house case seemed to be pretty
clear on its face we had all sorts of
video we had witness testimony we had
physical evidence demonstrating that
written house acted in self-defense in
this particular case there's a lack of
clarity about what actually happened
surrounding the death of ahmedabary so
his actual death was caught on camera uh
all you can see is a a series of trucks
a couple of trucks that are set up
across the road everybody tries to run
between the trucks there's apparently a
confrontation between him and a guy who
is holding a gun he goes for the gun and
he is shot in the process it seems like
the entire case comes down to the
question of whether these citizens were
actually legally entitled to try and
make a citizen's arrest against arbor
the original the original accusation is
that arbury was basically just a black
guy jogging in the neighborhood and some
white racist spotted a black guy jogging
in the neighborhood started trying to
track him down and effectuate a
citizen's arrest but it now appears that
there may be additional evidence coming
out that either arberry was engaged in
some sort of crime or that people
suspected he might be engaged in some
sort of crime and that's why they were
they were chasing him down
yeah ben the evidence that came out on
friday through testimony of a glenn
county police officer robert rash really
changed the game for the defense so you
hit the nail on the head the key to this
case is the citizens arrest statute so
it's it's a twofold defense first the
mcmichaels and roddy bryant the three
defendants have to be justified in
engaging in this citizen's arrest or
attempting to perform a citizen's arrest
on ahmad arbury then the second part is
a self-defense argument similar to what
we've seen now you can't get the benefit
of self-defense if you're the
initial aggressor or provoked the attack
upon yourself that's why
this citizen's arrest piece is so
critical in the case without it it would
be difficult for the mcmichaels to
overcome that rule which is called the
initial aggressor rule but here if they
engaged in a lawful citizen's arrest
under the georgia statute which was in
place at the time this happened then we
turned to the argument of self-defense
but it really hinges on the citizens
arrest law which means that there is a
reasonable and probable suspicion that a
felony had been committed and then the
defendants are justified in in the
citizens arrest so what happened on
friday was a game changer and i suspect
that this case will get more media
attention because it is not as cut and
dry as it originally seemed when we
first saw that video so evidence came
out that ahmad arbory had been caught on
camera at the loc at this site so it's a
house under construction owned by this
man larry english he had been caught
five times uh on camera at night prior
to the day of his death so a lot came
into play through
body cam footage relating to police
response by this witness that was on the
stand glenn county police officer robert
rash now on the video you see miss you
see officer rash you see the mick
michaels and they're talking about what
they knew and this happened february
11th ben this the the ahmad army died
february 23rd so this is this is insight
into what they knew at the time which is
the critical piece to establish a
defense under the
the citizens arrest statute they knew
that he had been there five times they
had heard that something had been stolen
from the property they uh they were told
that by officer rash that if ahmad
arbree was in this house they didn't
know who it was at the time but the
individual they confirmed it was the
same person that they'd seen before
that it would be trespassing loitering
or maybe something more leaving that
door open to establish a possible felony
there had been items missing from the
house nobody knew who took them at the
time and in addition to that
body cam footage shows officer rash
going into the house
guns drawn flashlight on showing a
pretty severe situation to find this
person who ended up being a mod arbory
seen on tape at this location now the
suspicion was suspicion of a burglary
which is ending a dwelling with the
intent to commit a crime so this is
insight into what the mcmichaels were
thinking at the time they were even told
by officer rash you know if you see this
guy
here's here's larry english's number you
let let the mcmichaels know so there's a
little bit more to the story at the end
of the day what it appears based on this
this testimony and body cam video that
mcmichaels knew that ahmad arbree had
been seen at night in this structure
items have been missing and travis
mcmichael says in the body cam footage
that he believes he'd seen arbory before
and that he believed that he was armed
so suddenly there's a new narrative here
and there is information to support the
mcmichael side of the case where they
say they chased him on arbory because
they believed that he may have committed
a crime that they had seen him before
and that they believed him to be armed
which is why they picked up guns before
they got on the road now
whether or not this satisfies the jury
only time will tell there's more
evidence to come but it was certainly a
game-changing day for the defense where
suddenly there are facts and information
and testimony and body cam video to
support the mcmichaels side of the case
to get to that uh citizens arrest law
now ben one more point and it's really
important and i don't think anybody's
really talking about it in order to use
this citizen's arrest law the defense
has to show that they were justified by
a preponderance of the evidence
now why does that matter
that means that it's 5149 right so it's
a different standard of proof than
beyond a reasonable doubt so and it's a
lower standard of proof for them to use
this as a defense so if they're able to
establish a defense under the citizen's
arrest law and and justify
their
they're chasing about aubry in the truck
and all of that
then the self-defense argument is a bit
more clear-cut because we see it on the
video so that's that's the hurdle to
overcome and there's certainly evidence
to support the defense side of the case
that is new and
this is the reason why we wait for the
facts to come out ben because there are
two sides to this and and it there's
there's a decent case for the defense
now and we'll continue to watch the
trial unfold
so misty obviously a lot of the media
coverage at the time focused in on the
actual shooting uh which was pretty hard
to watch obviously it also focused in
obviously on the race of the the victim
uh or alleged victim and and the race of
the defendant
in this particular case there was also
some some kind of loose talk about the
kind of language that these guys had
used has there been anything admitted
into testimony or evidence at this point
demonstrating that they were using
racial slurs about arberry either
surrounding his attempted arrest
supposedly or around his death
so there have not been racial slurs
there they called him a joker they said
he was trapped by a rat that did all
come into evidence and that was captured
on body cam footage what we do know is
going to happen uh there was some
pre-trial motion practice with respect
to evidence and one item that is
admitted is that the mcmichaels on the
back of their car have a
georgia a prior georgia flag and it's a
it's a confederate flag sticker on the
back of their truck so that was
ultimately admitted into evidence
presumably when we talk about this uh
citizens arrest statute you know they're
engaging in this chase with the mud
arbory and they're asking him to stop
and i'm assuming it's going to come in
in that way and that was part of the
argument that you know why would he stop
under these particular circumstances
they're not law enforcement so he did
not have any obligation to do so so that
is going to come in but keep in mind
they're not charged with a hate crime in
this particular case there is a federal
indictment for uh for civil rights
violations that's coming down the pike
uh but that is not a factor in this
particular case this is all about
whether or not there's a justified
citizen's arrest in self-defense or was
it false imprisonment assault felony
murder and that's what the the linchpin
is in this case
so misty this could look very much like
sort of the situation with george
zimmerman where you have george
zimmerman and trayvon martin and
zimmerman according to the the witness
testimony in his own testimony zimmerman
thinks that there's possibly a crime
going on he trails trayvon martin
trayvon martin uh just sees a guy
trailing him confronts him they get in a
fight he's beating up zimmerman and
zimmerman shoots and kills him so that
could theoretically be a
self-defense you know situation in which
both sides are sort of misconstruing
what's going on it sounds like that
could be this as well if arbor was not
in fact committing a crime it could have
been exactly the same sort of situation
that they had preponderance of the
evidence to believe that he was
committing a crime they started tracking
him down all he sees is a bunch of white
guys following him in in trucks or
trying to cut him off within trucks of
the confederate flag he tries to escape
and he gets shot in the process and
that's still possibly a self-defense
case is what you're saying
exactly it is still a self-defense case
and and the uh it's very similar to
george zimmerman and this law in place
in georgia this this citizens arrest law
is really the key to the case as you
said ben because it's all about what the
mcmichaels and mr brydon so there's
three defendants and there's slightly
different defenses for for each but just
in general it depends on what they knew
at the time so obviously it's a better
sell to a jury if a crime was committed
right
that's what the defense would would hope
for and they made some points in the
case where they said that the the police
investigation was not thorough that
certain areas were not canvassed so
perhaps something could have been
dropped along the way you know they're
putting down in the jury's head but even
if a crime wasn't committed
if there was a reasonable suspicion
to think that a crime was based on the
information that they knew at the time
then they can have the benefit of the
uh
citizens arrest law
in addition to the self-defense statute
which again they have to get over that
initial aggressor which is where the
citizens of wrestle comes in so
you you are right on point it's a very
very similar case in that sense and it
really does hinge on whether or not they
were justified in this pursuit and you
know what based on some of the evidence
that just came out just the story is has
been turned on its head because now we
have insight without their testimony you
know on video about what they knew prior
to february 23rd now
that's absolutely critical because
that's what matters there's a lot of red
herrings in this case but focusing in on
the real issue what did they know at the
time and and that's the key
so missy final question for you
obviously one of the issues in the media
coverage has been the race of the jury
in the arbory case and it really is in
the the mcmichael case because arbor was
the person who was shot michael is the
defendant but in the mcmichael case the
race of the jury is apparently one black
person and 11 people who are not black
the media have made much of this fact
the suggestion being that if he's
convicted then justice has been done but
if he is if they are not convicted of
michaels then this is because of white
racism
how did the the constituency of the jury
play in in terms in terms of race there
have been a lot of accusations that
black jurors were being struck
specifically because of their race is
there any evidence to back that
so the judge actually the prosecution
did what's called the baton challenges
where where you say um hey you know are
you you can't strike jurors on the basis
of race alone that's a supreme court
case that that held that point um what
the defense has to do in response or the
party being challenged just to do in
response is to lay down a legitimate
non-discriminatory reason for excluding
certain jurors and in this case
they were able to do so there were many
jurors who made statements about having
preconceived notions about the case
already have drawn conclusions about the
case the type of stuff that's normal to
exclude jurors for so look that was
challenged um and the defense was able
to justify each and every person that
had been dismissed so look this is just
this is a common practice in uh criminal
defense law the challenges come up all
the time and so long as you hit that
legal standard of legitimate legitimate
non-discriminatory reason you've
satisfied your burden as the person as
the party that's being challenged in the
case so uh look the judge made a comment
that that i thought was a little
inappropriate and i really like this
judge actually but you know he said it
looks like there may have been
discrimination i don't think that was
right because under the law the court
only has so much discretion and if you
satisfy that burden legitimate
non-discriminatory reason then the trial
goes on and and there's there is no
issue from a legal perspective
well that is misty maris she's a trial
attorney based in new york city you can
check out her new podcast called legal
brief it's on a platform called call in
and she covers all of these criminal
justice stories for hlms you really
appreciate the time the insight
thank you ben always happy to be on
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed